In the figure above, triangle
ABC is inscribed in the
circle with center O and diameter AC.
So AC is the diameter right over there.
If AB is equal to AO,
so this is equal to that
right over there, AO is the radius so AB
is the same length of
the radius, what is the
degree measure of angle ABO?
So the main realization here is that
this length right over here,
AO, the length of segment AO,
that's a radius so this is
a radius right over here.
It goes from the center of the circle
to the circle itself, to point A.
Well this is also a radius of a circle.
This is going to have the same length.
They already told us that
AB has the same length
as AO which, because AO
is a radius and OB is also
a radius, it's going to have
the same length as OB or BO.
And so then what do we have?
We have an equilateral triangle.
What do we know about
an equilateral triangle?
All of the sides have
the same length, but also
all of these interior angles are
going to have the same measures.
So that angle is equal to
that is equal to that angle
and all three of them,
because they have to add up
to 180 degrees, and you
have three equal angles
adding up to 180 degrees, each of these
have to be 60 degree angles.
So angle ABO, which is the
one they're asking about,
is going to be a 60 degree angle.